[Music]
in the 1920s the German mathematician
David Hilbert devised a famous thought
experiment to show us just how hard it
is to wrap our minds around the concept
of infinity
imagine a hotel with an infinite number
of rooms and a very hard working night
manager one night the infinite hotel is
completely full totally booked up with
an infinite number of guests a man walks
into the hotel and asks for a room
rather than turn him down the night
manager decides to make room for him how
easy he asks the guests in room number
one to move to room two the guest in
room two to move to room three and so on
every guest moves from room number n to
room number n plus one since there are
an infinite number of rooms there is a
new room for each existing guest this
leaves room one open for the new
customer the process can be repeated for
any finite number of new guests if say a
tour bus unloads 40 new people looking
for rooms then every existing guest just
moves from room number n to room number
n plus 40 thus opening up the first 40
rooms but now an infinitely large bus
with a countably infinite number of
passengers pulls up to rent rooms
countably infinite is the key now the
infinite bus of infinite passengers
perplexes the night manager at first but
he realizes there's a way to place each
new person he asks the guest in room 1
to move to room 2 he then asks the guest
in room 2 to move to room 4 the guest in
room 3 to move to room 6 and so on each
current guest moves from room number n
to room number 2n
filling up only the infinite
even-numbered rooms by doing this he has
now emptied all of the infinitely many
odd numbered rooms which are then taken
by the people filing off the infinite
bus everyone's happy and the hotels
business is booming more than ever well
actually it is booming exactly the same
amount as ever
banking an infinite number of dollars a
night word spreads about this incredible
hotel people pour in from far and wide
one night the unthinkable happens the
night manager looks outside and sees an
infinite line of infinitely large buses
each with a countably infinite number of
passengers what can he do if he cannot
find rooms for them the hotel will lose
out on an infinite amount of money and
he will surely lose his job luckily he
remembers that around the Year 300 BCE
Euclid proved that there is an infinite
quantity of prime numbers so to
accomplish this seemingly impossible
task of finding infinite beds for
infinite buses of infinite weary
travelers the night manager assigns
every current guest to the first prime
number two raised to the power of their
current room number so the current
occupant of room number seven goes to
room number two to the seventh power
which is room 128 the night manager then
takes the people on the first of the
infinite buses and assigns them to the
room number of the next prime three
raised to the power of their seat number
on the bus so the person in seat number
seven on the first bus goes to room
number three to the seventh power or
room number 2187 this continues for all
of the first bus the passengers on the
second bus are assigned powers of the
next prime five the following bus powers
of seven each bus follows powers of
eleven powers of 13 powers of seventeen
etc since each of these numbers only has
one and the natural number powers of
their prime number base as factors there
are no overlapping room numbers all the
buses passengers fan out into rooms
using unique room assignment schemes
based on unique prime numbers
in this way the night manager can
accommodate every passenger on every bus
although there will be many rooms that
go unfilled like room 6 since 6 is not a
power of any prime number luckily his
bosses weren't very good in math so his
job is safe the night managers
strategies are only possible because
while the infinite hotel is certainly a
logistical nightmare it only deals with
the lowest level of infinity namely the
countable infinity of the natural
numbers 1 2 3 4 and so on Georg Cantor
called this level of infinity LF zero we
use natural numbers for the room numbers
as well as the seat numbers on the buses
if we were dealing with higher orders of
infinity such as that of the real
numbers these structured strategies
would no longer be possible as we have
no way to systematically include every
number the real number infinite hotel
has a negative number rooms in the
basement
fractional rooms so the guy in room one
half always suspects he has less room
than the guy in room 1 square root rooms
like room radical 2 and room PI where
the guests expect free dessert what
self-respecting night manager would ever
want to work there even for an infinite
salary but over at Hilbert's infinite
hotel where there's never any vacancy
and always room for more the scenario is
faced by the ever diligent and maybe too
hospitable night manager served to
remind us of just how hard it is for our
relatively finite minds to grasp a
concept as large as infinity maybe you
can help tackle these problems after a
good night's sleep
but honestly we might need you to change
rooms at 2 a.m.
[Music]
you